[Musik]
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka
genannt auch heute wieder ein tag an dem
das coroner thema das politische
geschehen beherrscht die bundesregierung
hatte neue einreisebeschränkungen
beschlossen
tschechien und tirol werden als
sogenannte mutations gebiete eingestuft
damit gelten strengere
einreisebestimmungen neben den schon
bestehenden grenzkontrollen zu
österreich wird es ab sonntag auch
kontrollen an der grenze zu tschechien
gehen
damit soll der import der neuen mutanten
eingedämmt werden
von deutschland fernhalten lassen sie
sich aber ja eh nicht mehr sie sind ja
bereits im land wegen der virus
mutationen warnte bundeskanzlerin merkel
bei ihrer regierungserklärung heute
erneut vor einer dritten welle die
debatte bundestag und die kritik die ihr
aus dem parlament entgegen schallte hat
matthias kubitz verfolgt
draußen shutdown drinnen attacken
mächtig druck unter der kuppel und unter
den masken stoisch wird die kanzlerin 22
minuten lang erklären nur sowie
beschlossen könne man handeln
das was wir gestern vereinbart haben
davon bin ich überzeugt ist geeignet
erforderlich und verhältnismäßig es gibt
insbesondere auch weiterhin kein
milderes mittel als konsequente kontakt
beschränken in allen genannten bereichen
wirklich auch nach einem jahr noch trotz
allem was wir gelernt haben das ist
bestenfalls einfallslos mit sicherheit
frau merkel ist das nicht alternativlos
viele menschen haben sich mehr erwartet
als einen frischen haarschnitt ich frage
mich wollen sie den mittelstand das
rückgrat unseres wohlstands vernichten
wollen sie uns auf den stand eines
entwicklungslandes bringen
shut down ohne beteiligung des
bundestags das ist die grundsätzliche
kritik quer durch die opposition
doch ein wenig war es heute auch eine
stunde kritischer selbsterkenntnis
wir hatten auch eine risikoanalyse zu
pandemien aber wir haben sie nicht ernst
genug genommen und dementsprechend
müssen wir uns intensiver auch mit einer
katastrophenvorsorge beschäftigen wir
haben auch nicht die gesetzlichen
grundlagen wir müssen katastrophen üben
wir müssen automatismen schaffen dass
wir mit diesen katastrophen besser
klarkommen darum geht es jetzt um das
muss die lehre aus dieser pandemie seien
die kanzlerin gesteht ein letzten sommer
habe man zu zögerlich auf virologen
gehört wir haben auf die anzeichen der
zweiten welle und die warnungen
verschiedener wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hin nicht früh und nicht
konsequent genug
das öffentliche leben wieder
heruntergefahren so stünde bei jeder
entscheidung die trauer um die korona
toten mit im raum diese verstorbenen
es sind jetzt weit mehr als 60.000
menschen das sind unsere mütter väter
kinder verwandte freunde die wir nicht
bewahren konnten zu wenig selbstkritik
beklagt die linke das sterben geht
schließlich weiter
täglich sterben weiter viele menschen in
alten- und pflegeheim weiß ich nicht
geschützt werden und der impfstoffe
das sterben in den heim ist vielleicht
das dunkelste kapitel der letzten
jahrzehnte zuversichtliches kaum zu
hören heute angesichts der mutanten und
des impfstoff mangels dennoch in wenigen
wochen wissen wir ob wir impfen das
virus noch übertragen dann können wir
freiheitsrechte nach und nach zurück
gewinnen
wer heute mehr verspricht handelt
fahrlässig die grünen würden gern schon
mal den pandemie wortschatz erweitern
das gegenteil von lock down ist ja was
eigentlich
die akademie wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen ja und gleichzeitig sollten
wir uns jetzt mit der frage
auseinandersetzen was kommt eigentlich
danach was kommt eigentlich danach
nachdem lockdown und dem lockdown wann
kommt eigentlich open ab frühestens am
dritten märz dann will sich die
bundeskanzlerin wieder mit den ländern
zusammen
im bundestag jedenfalls geht's merkel
den menschen ihr aber schaut beim
hygiene fauxpas die ein oder andere
kamera zu immer also an die maske denken
über die kritik an ihrer politik werde
ich mit der bundeskanzlerin morgen
übrigens selbst sprechen wir sind zum
interview verabredet hier im heute
journal im bundestag sagte angela merkel
das virus richte sich nicht nach daten
man könne deshalb noch keine termine
nennen wann genau zum beispiel die
geschäfte alle wieder öffnen dürfen
darin liegt allerdings ein dilemma denn
das wichtigste für geschäftsleute sind
ja nun mal termine
sie brauchen einen zeitplan auf den sie
sich einstellen können doch genau den
gibt es nicht der siebte märz ist auch
kein stichtag auf den sie sich jetzt
verlässlich einrichten könnten weil
ihnen niemand zu sagen will dass die
infektions lage das dann auch
tatsächlich hergibt der frust im
einzelhandel ist entsprechend groß
berichtet simon wechselt die
shoppingcity gleicht einer geisterstadt
in diesem februar metzingen in baden
württemberg mit seinen 100 outlet
geschäften wie leergefegt im laden von
hugo boss bleibt die ware liegen zwei
mitarbeiter pro schicht beraten kunden
digital die anderen verkäufer sind in
kurzarbeit
wir wünschen uns mehr konsistenz von der
politik und wir brauchen eine klare
zeitliche perspektive und
schnellstmöglich die benennung eines
datums wann wir wieder öffnen können
normalerweise kommen vier millionen
besucher pro jahr in die stadt und
besucher das bedeutet in metzingen immer
auch kundschaft die fehlt jetzt nicht
nur für die outlets auch für kleine
händler in der innenstadt
das belastet langfristig auch die
finanzen der kommune sagt der
oberbürgermeister
es fehlt ganz einfach das leben und das
ist sehr zu bedauern will
je länger dieser lockeren dauert umso
größer laufen wir gefahr dass wir dies
auch nicht mehr wieder so einrichten
können wie es davor war weil die
angebote irgendwann
nicht aufrechterhalten werden können
weil es insolvenzen gibt weiß
einzelhändler und gastronomen gibt
hoteliers die irgendwann nicht mehr
durchhalten können diesen lockte
weltkonzerne wie hugo boss haben den
vorteil ihre ware in ausländischen
filialen verkaufen zu können kleinere
modehändler dagegen sitzen bundesweit
auf einem berg an unverkaufter kleidung
viele warten noch auf staatshilfe für
viele textil und mode händler kann das
aus bedeuten das sind wahrscheinlich
weit mehr als 50.000 unternehmen die
jetzt aufgeben müssen weil eben die
hilfen die bisher überhaupt nicht
angekommen sind auch nicht ausreichen
werden und es keine perspektive nach
vorne gibt es ist kein licht am ende des
tunnels zu sehen bis zu 250.000
arbeitsplätze stünden auf dem spiel sagt
der verband auch handelsexperten halten
eine pleitewelle für wahrscheinlich ein
grund dafür die hilfsgelder würden
ungerecht verteilt da besteht ein
missverhältnis das unternehmen die
vorher schon angeschlagen waren nur weil
sie eine gewisse lobby haben wie
karstadt kaufhof relativ schnell immense
staatshilfen bekommen kleinere und
mittelgroße händler sich wochen und
monate lang die hacken ablaufen bis
heute nichts gesehen haben da muss
dringend nachgeschärft werden wir raus
aus der krise in der outletcity in
metzingen versuchen sie den kontakt zu
ihren kunden nicht zu verlieren
sie arbeiten mit influenza präsentieren
sich in sozialen medien und bieten
virtuelles shoppen an
das bringt ihnen gerade mal zehn prozent
des entgangenen umsatzes deshalb drängt
auch der bürgermeister auf eine schnelle
öffnung perspektive es gibt
einzelhändler die haben hervorragende
hygiene konzepte und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass es gelingen könnte mit
bestimmten auflagen unterschiedlicher
art tatsächlich auch das eine oder
andere früher und schneller zu öffnen um
die wirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen schäden an der stelle
in grenzen zu halten
doch die entscheidung ist gefallen
ladenschließungen bleiben ein mittel in
der pandemie bekämpfung keine öffnung
für weitere drei wochen viele
informationen rund um das coroner thema
finden sie bei uns immer auch online auf
ze erfreut etwa dazu wann und wie die
einzelnen bundesländer schulen und kitas
öffnen wollen jetzt erstmal die
nachrichten von heinz wolf in italien
hat ex fdp chef draghi für die geplante
regierungsbildung jetzt auch die
unterstützung der fünf sterne bewegung
die die stärkste kraft im parlament ist
in einer abstimmung der fünf sterne
mitglieder sprach sich eine mehrheit
dafür aus
draghi hatte in den vergangenen tagen
mit den parlamentsparteien über die
regierungsbildung beraten wird der
zustimmung der sterne bewegung erhält
trage ein weiteres positives signal dass
er mit einer großen mehrheit rechnen
kann
die usa halten auch unter dem neuen
präsidenten joe biden den druck auf
china aufrecht nach angaben des weißen
hauses hat beiden in einem ersten
telefonat mit dem chinesischen
präsidenten mit schuhen bin eine reihe
von streitpunkten angesprochen
unter anderem seine grundlegenden sorgen
über pekings unfaire wirtschaftliche
praktiken und auch über das vorgehen
pekings in hongkong und gegenüber den
uiguren
chinas präsident sprach dagegen von
inneren angelegenheiten chinas wie es
hieß und warnte auch vor einer
konfrontation
der bundestag hat mit den stimmen der
koalition den straftatbestand der
geldwäsche reformiert das verschleiern
von kriminellen profiten wird demnach
grundsätzlich strafbar unabhängig davon
durch welche straftat sie erworben
wurden
bisher konnte geldwäsche nur dann
verfolgt werden wenn das fragliche
vermögen aus ganz bestimmten straftaten
wie drogenhandel menschenhandel oder
schutzgeld erpressung stammt nach dem
tödlichen messerangriff in dresden
anfang oktober hat die
bundesanwaltschaft laut zdf
informationen anklage erhoben der
mutmaßliche attentäter soll aus
islamistischen und
homosexuellenfeindliche motiven zwei
touristen niedergestochen haben
ein mann starb das andere opfer
überlebte schwer verletzt
ob und wann es zum prozess kommt
entscheidet das oberlandesgericht
dresden rund ein halbes jahr nach der
umstrittenen präsidentenwahl in belarus
hat machthaber lukaschenko das verhalten
westlicher staaten stark kritisiert die
monatelangen massenproteste seien von
externen mächten künstlich erzeugt
worden
bei der eröffnung des allrussischen
volkskongresse stellte lukaschenko vor
den delegierten außerdem eine neue
verfassung in aussicht sie soll weniger
vollmachten für den präsidenten
enthalten anfang 2022 sollen die bürger
darüber abstimmen
seit jahrzehnten streiten china und
indien um ein grenzgebiet im himalaya
gebirge
nun haben die länder ihren konflikt
vorerst beigelegt und einen truppenabzug
vereinbart rund um den ballon sie in der
region ladakh haben erste
truppeneinheiten der indischen und
chinesischen armee mit dem rückzug von
der umstrittenen grenze begonnen nach
bewaffneten auseinandersetzungen in den
vergangenen monaten hatten beide seiten
zehntausende soldaten in der region
mobilisiert
auch in europa gibt es nach wie vor
grenzen die umstritten sind und kaum
etwas ist ja so explosiv wie ungeklärte
grenzfragen vor allem wenn die
bevölkerung innerhalb eines landes
darüber gespalten ist
der bürgerkrieg in nordirland ist noch
nicht so lange her
die troubles wie sie diese blutige zeit
nennen sind ein trauma bis heute jede
familie war in irgendeiner form
betroffen
die protestantischen notieren die sich
großbritannien zugehörig fühlen
genauso wie die katholischen die sich
die loslösung vom königreich wünschen
und die vereinigung mit der republik
irland gelöst ist das bis heute nicht
aber die mitgliedschaft in der eu halb
sehr weil es damit auf der irischen
insel keine physische grenzen ergab
dieses problem wurde bei der ganzen
rexit debatte von den engländern
weitgehend verdrängt das rächte sich
erst bei den verhandlungen mit der eu
und jetzt in der neuen praxis realität
andreas stadt berichtet
geduld bringt rosen vier jahre lang
während der praxis verhandlungen waren
sie beim belfaster garten großhandel
helmen geduldig doch die lkw die rosen
aus großbritannien bringen kommen nicht
mehr erklärt inhaber robin mercer grund
der sonderstatus nordirland das als teil
des vereinigten königreichs weiter im eu
binnenmarkt ist britische erde darf
nicht mehr eingeführt werden über die
neue zollgrenze die das eigene land
zweiter gewächse aus großbritannien wir
halten uns schon gedacht dass wir
probleme kriegen
deshalb haben wir im dezember rosen
vorräte angelegt aber wir werden nigl
der welche bekommen das ist unmöglich
geworden
sie suchen sich jetzt lieferanten aus
der eu rechnen mit höheren preisen
herben umsatzeinbußen der last-minute
handelsvertrag brachte sich neue regeln
formulare über nacht überforderte zoll
kontrolleure treffen nun auf lieferanten
mit falschen oder gar keinen papieren
statt obst und gemüse aus britannien
leere supermarktregale und in wenigen
wochen sind weitere verschärfungen der
kontrollen geplant noch mehr regeln
die gelten die übergangsphase muss
verlängert werden als erster teil einer
größeren lösung man sollte nicht
vergessen dass unsere händler gerade den
perfekten sturm durchmachen braig sit
und corona die probleme mit dem
sonderstatus nordirlands müssen umgehend
gelöst werden doch einen perfekten sturm
verschlimmern wenn es jemand schafft
dann brüssel und london
seit tagen über ziehen sich beide seiten
mit vorwürfen britische forderungen nach
änderungen am eben erst geschlossenen
vertrag in brüssel
vom heutigen krisentreffen in london ab
vor gerade mal acht wochen haben wir
eine vielzahl von praktischen lösungen
gefunden die helfen den übergang in
nordirland zu erleichtern
sie sollten von britischer seite auch
schleunigst umgesetzt werden london es
zurück die eu spiele falsch in
nordirland denn brüssel wollte corona
impfstofflieferungen über nordirland
nach großbritannien verhindern
über eine sonderklausel des brh exit
vertrags die grenzkontrollen ermöglicht
seitdem erklärt die britische regierung
die regelungen zu nordirland haben sich
als nicht praxistauglich erwiesen
schaden der wirtschaft und man riskiere
ein wiederaufflammen von gewalt die
regeln und institutionen die für
stabilität standen werden gerade
zerstört danach ist alles möglich sehr
kleine gruppen können dann weitere
unruhen anfachen gruppen die schon
sichtbare zeichen in belfast
hinterlassen den langsam klar wird man
ist wirtschaftlich teil der eu geblieben
und dem geld folgt oft die gesinnung der
brh exit ist realität die abspaltung vom
vereinigten königreich droht realität zu
werden dass es da in nordirland bei
bloßen drohungen von gewalt bleibt
unrealistisch in washington geht das im
pitch und verfahren gegen donald trump
in die nächste runde
die demokraten die da gewissermaßen als
ankläger auftreten setzen vor allem
darauf der öffentlichkeit noch mal vor
augen zu führen wie gewaltig und
gewalttätig dieser sturm aufs kapitän
war dass es sich nicht einfach nur um
eine eskalierte demonstration handelte
sondern dass da ein mod unterwegs war
der töten wollte so dass politiker unter
anderem james vizepräsident zurecht um
ihr leben fürchteten der hass und die
angst werden vor allem mit videos
dokumentiert von denen manche bisher
noch nicht öffentlich waren aus
washington
kompanie es ist eine sammlung
dramatischer teils schockierender und
auch neuer videos die die anlegerinnen
und anleger dem senat und der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren
die einzelteile sollen sich zu einem
präzisen gesamtbild der ereignisse vom 6
januar zusammenfügen und beweisen
donald trump war kein unbeteiligter
sondern der insider in chief der chef
als stifter die aufständischen sagten
sie kommen nach washington wegen
präsident trump er lud sie ein mit
klaren instruktionen für einen
bestimmten ort eine bestimmte zeit und
mit klaren befehlen
wir wurden eingeladen vom präsidenten
der vereinigten staaten schreit einer
ausschnitte wie diese werden zusammen
montiert mit statements von trump sie
sollen beweisen dass die anhänger auf
seine befehle reagierten
der aufstand war bis dahin die
gewalttätigste und gefährlichste episode
in donalds fortlaufenden
verhaltensmustern und der gewohnheit
gewalt anzustacheln hält mike pence ruft
die menge die auch einen galgen
aufgestellt hat doch anstatt ihm
beizustehen twittert rand keine zehn
minuten später
myspace hatte nicht den mut zu tun was
getan werden sollte um unser land zu
verteidigen denn pence hatte sich trans
anordnung widersetzt wahl stimmen für
ungültig zu erklären
er musste sich im capitol nur wenige
meter von den aufständischen entfernt
verstecken
diese kamera zeigt wie er sand familie
in sicherheit gebracht wird
journalisten im capitol berichteten sie
hörten randalierer sagen sie suchen nach
pence um ihn hinzurichten
als die lage weiter eskaliert wenden
sich republikaner direkt an ihren
präsidenten der präsident sie müssen das
stoppen sie sind der einzige der das
aufhalten kann
doch schwamm reagiert erst nach über
einer weiteren stunde fordert erst dann
den mob auf nach hause zu gehen
allerdings nicht ohne seine behauptung
vom wahlbetrug zu wiederholen und mit
dem gruß wir lieben euch ihr seid etwas
ganz besonderes zwei nachmittage liefert
die anklageseite eine detailreiche
darstellung bei den republikanern
beeindruckt dass längst nicht alle
die stimmen für nicht schuldig dürften
heute mehr geworden sein
ich glaube die meisten republikaner
finden die anklage beleidigend und
absurd nachdem demokraten bekommen ab
morgen jones verteidiger das wort die
können offenbar weiter darauf zählen
dass nicht genügend republikaner gegen
ihren ex präsidenten
stimmen werden und jetzt nochmal heinz
wolf zunächst mit nachrichten aus der
finanzwelt
die commerzbank hat seit anfang dieses
jahres einen neuen vorstandschef manfred
knof heute hat die bank eckpunkte ihrer
neuen strategie vorgestellt frank
bethmann
wie sehen die aus ja der neue muss die
commerzbank zügig wieder auf kurs
bringen denn von dem ist deutschlands
zweitgrößte privatbank spätestens seit
der finanzkrise 2008 abgekommen damals
musste der staat als retter einspringen
seitdem scheiterten mehrere versuche die
bank neu aufzustellen das große problem
des instituts es verdient zu wenig geld
deshalb jetzt der nächste anlauf mit
neuem vorstandsvorsitzenden seine
strategie sieht harte einschnitte bis 20
24 vor
so ist der abbau von 10.000
vollzeitstellen geplant ebenso die
verringerung von derzeit 790 auf dann
nur noch 450 filialen dazu eine massive
kostensenkung eine radikalkur also die
börse aber bleibt skeptisch der kurs der
aktie sind heute deutlich um 6 prozent
besonders im fokus natürlich der massive
stellenabbau
die konzernspitze sagt in deutschland
werde jeder dritte arbeitsplatz von den
streichungen betroffen sein
das sind natürlich sehr harte
einschnitte für die belegschaft auf der
anderen seite muss man sagen dass die
commerzbank seit jahren verluste
schreibt insofern auch drastische
maßnahmen erforderlich sind
herter könnten die zeiten auch für die
kunden der commerzbank werden knof
deutete heute an dass man zwar vorerst
am kostenlosen girokonto festhalten
wurde dass man aber sehr wohl darüber
nachdenke negativzinsen im größeren
umfang an die privatkunden weiterzugeben
frank wittmann vielen dank zum start der
alpinen ski wm in cortina d'ampezzo gab
es für das deutsche team eine medaille
im super g mit nur sieben hundertstel
rückstand auf den sieger der in
österreicher vincent kriechmayr hat
romed baumann silber gewonnen
mit mut zum risiko und einer
nervenstarken vaters der gebürtige
tiroler romed baumann über die wm piste
für österreich war der 35-jährige vor
zwei jahren nicht mehr gut genug
nach dem wechsel zum deutschen
skiverband gelingt den jetzt sein
größter erfolg silber um sieben
hundertstel hinter seinem früheren
landsmann vincent kriechmayr und vor dem
franzosen alexis pinturault behauptet
nur funktioniert weil ihm ein neues
umfeld habt ihr mit lappen die mich
unterstützt haben
die möglich gemacht haben und das ist
ein großes dankeschön
ich freue mich irrsinnig für rottweil
jetzt schon einige mal erwähnt vor allem
wir nur für österreich von ist war auf
der buhmann der nation viele male zu
unrecht hat immer abstempelt ohren und
ein toller charakter und die schreiben
es ist das beste wm ergebnis eines
deutschen ski fahrers im super g der fc
bayern münchen hat die fußball club wm
in katar gewonnen
das finale am abend gegen die
mexikanische mannschaft tigress
entschieden die bayern mit 1 0 für sich
bei den münchner favoriten beginnt in
die reuss anstelle des in katar corona
positiv getestet und thomas müller die
bayern von beginn an präsent und
tonangebend unter als joshua kimmig nach
18 minuten das 1 0 erzielt scheint alles
den erwarteten gang zu gehen
doch wird der treffer überprüft und vom
reichen schiedsrichter zurecht wegen
abseits zurück genommen da der
ursprünglich passive lewandowski in der
sichtlichen behinderung von peter
gussmann aktiviert auch danach bleibt es
ein spiel auf ein tor und sein schuss
testet hörbar die standfestigkeit des
mexikanischen gehäuses in hälfte zwei
dann nach 59 minuten eine doublette zum
vermeintlichen ersten bayern-treffer mit
dem unterschied dass das tor von barca
war nach videobeweis diesmal anerkennung
findet
bei diesem hochverdienten 1 0 erfolg
bleibt es dann auf sodass feiern die
münchner nun alle sechs möglichen titel
in einer saison gewonnen haben
mehr geht auch für den fc bayern ist es
ungewohnt überhaupt zuschauer zu sehen
was den fußballern die stadien das sind
den filmemachern die kinos und die sind
bei uns ja auch leer
und damit gibt es auch keine premieren
auf großer leinwand keine roten teppiche
mit jubelndem publikum neue filme gibt
es trotzdem und auch wettbewerber die
oscar-verleihung etwa wird es auch in
diesem jahr geben allerdings frühestens
im april und nicht nur in einer großen
gala aus der ley sondern verteilt auf
mehrere orte jeweils in kleinerem rahmen
auch bei der berlinale ist diesmal alles
anders normalerweise wäre sie heute
abend feierlich eröffnet worden
das fällt flach aber stattfinden wird
sie trotzdem
allerdings erstmal nur online aus berlin
stephan merseburger und nadja nasse
schnee eisige temperaturen und gähnende
leere
trees wo heute eigentlich der teufel los
sein sollte blick zurück in bessere
berlinale tage presse und publikum aus
dem häuschen weil weltstars nach berlin
gekommen sind in diesem jahr ist alles
anders
wegen corinna die leitung hat das
festival in zweigeteilt im märz findet
ein reiner branchentreff online statt
das öffentliche feste will mit publikum
und stars im juni so gott will es ist
ein riesenvorteil wenn filmemacher
publikum presse und stars zur selben
zeit am selben ort alle zusammenkommen
das geht aber nicht die alternative wäre
gewesen das festival abzusagen
heute wurden die 15 wettbewerbsfilme
bekannt gegeben allein vier sind aus
deutschland
daniel brühl zeigt sein regie-debüt
nebenan
spielt einen filmstar kann ich das
programm haben sein nachbar dargestellt
von peter kroth droht seine karriere mit
enthüllungen zu zerstören
ich kann eure wohnung von meinem fenster
aus
ebenfalls im wettbewerb fabian von
dominik graf mit albrecht schuch und tom
schilling eine zdf-koproduktion nach dem
roman von erich kästner
berlin die wilden 20er jahre und der
tanz auf dem vulkan neigen sich dem ende
entgegen
unheil liegt in der luft der moment der
welt premiere ist eigentlich immer ein
wahnsinnig wichtiger und auch
emotionaler moment wo die arbeit das
licht der welt erblickt das findet nun
mehr oder weniger hinter verschlossenen
türen statt gleichzeitig ist es gut dass
dieses festival sich dazu entschieden
hat trotzdem stattzufinden
der wettbewerb schafft aufmerksamkeit
für anspruchsvolle und teils sperrige
filme die sie sonst nicht bekommen
daher gibt es auch zweifel daran dass
die zweiteilung des festivals richtig
ist was macht den wettbewerb aus nicht
zuerst eine jury hinter verschlossenen
türen sondern eben der rote teppich der
glamour der hype das publikum das
beflügelt auch filme und hilft diesen
weit über das festival hinaus
aber es gab auch druck aus der
filmindustrie den bedeutenden filmmarkt
der berlinale jetzt wenigstens virtuell
stattfinden zu lassen
das hat jetzt schon richtig lange kein
markt mehr stattgefunden und es gibt
eine ganze menge filme die darauf warten
gekauft zu werden und verkauft zu werden
und das dann deals zustande kommen die
neuen filme nirgend den weg ins kino
ebnen
das publikums festival im juni für heißt
es dass der unter michel pfeiffer jodie
foster benedict cumberbatch und michael
caine
da kommt doch glatt vorfreude auf und
noch wollen wir in unserer corona trist
es daran glauben ein bisschen zumindest
einen vorteil hat die virtuelle
virtuelle berlinale aber das sonst
übliche frieren auf dem roten teppich
entfällt und dieses jahr würden damen in
dünner abendrobe auch noch ganz
besonders frieren
woher diese ihre kälte kommt erklärt
gleich katja horneffer in ihrem
wetterbericht und um 0 uhr gibt's dann
unser heute schon ein update minuten
also 1 glückte mir auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren warum ist
es eigentlich so eiskalt dieses starke
hoch über skandinavien ist schuld es
schiebt die kälte heran und letztes
wochenende setzte auch noch nordost
sturm ein süd westwärts wälzte sich die
frostluft schwer und träge aus südwesten
drückte ein tief milde und feuchte
dagegen diese deutlich leichtere luft
strömt über die eiseskälte und an dieser
grenze entwickelten sich massive
schneefälle und gefährlicher eisregen
die sind jetzt weg der schnee aber
bleibt über ihm sacken die temperaturen
nachts unter klarem himmel bei
windstille auf minus 20 grad oder
darunter
erst zum beispiel gab es in bayern minus
21 grad und heute erwarten wir minus
sechs bis minus 20 grad
meist ist der himmel klar und nur in
sachsen an der ostsee gibt es noch
einige schneeschauer morgen dann strahlt
die sonne und ein sich an der ostsee
gibt es noch ein paar letzte
schneeschauer der wind nimmt zu er kommt
aus nördlichen bis östlichen richtungen
und es bleibt dauerfrost ich in
deutschland mit höchsttemperaturen
morgen zwischen minus acht und minus ein
grad das wochenende wird sehr sonnig und
ein kleines bisschen milder
am sonntag erwarten uns minus fünf bis
plus fünf grad und am montag kommen dann
von westen schneeregen und regenfälle
heran wenn die auf den tiefgefrorenen
boden fallen wird es spiegelglatt